翻訳: Keisuke Yamashita
校正: Hiroko Kawano
（拍手）
突然ですが
私はトイレが大好きです
小学校２年生の時に
頻尿になってから
トイレを探す毎日が続き
トイレを探すことが癖になり
それがきっかけで
私はトイレを愛して止まなくなりました
悩んだり 怒ったり 泣きたくなったり
そうして そんな時に行くのがトイレです
トイレが無いってなっただけで
私はもう不安でいっぱいになります
トイレの事ばかり
毎日考えているので
夢の中にはトイレがしょっちゅう出てきます
そこで私はなんとか
「あー おしっこがしたい」と思って
トイレに行くんですけど
すっきりしなくて
いつも悔しい思いをします
ただ起きた時に
「あー 漏らしてなくてよかった」
と思うことがしょっちゅうです
皆さんにも
今日は私がどれだけトイレを愛しているか
その愛が少しでも伝わって
少しでもみなさんに
トイレに愛を持っていただくために
お話したいと思います
さて 皆さん
トイレについて
皆さんはどのようにお考えですか？
当たり前にある
普段 日常生活でとても当たり前にあって
意識することもなく使っているし
感謝することもなく使っていると思います
もし感謝するとすれば
お腹が痛くなってトイレに駆け込んだ時に
「あー ここにトイレがあって
本当によかった」と思う時ぐらいだと思います
ただ ヒトが生まれて
一つの場所に住み始めて
定住が始まってから
実は「トイレの戦い」
というものがありました
そしてトイレの戦いっていうのは
今でも実は 連綿と続いているんです
皆さん
水洗トイレがいつ生まれたか
ご存知ですか？
実は 今から4,000年前
メソポタミア文明の遺跡から
トイレが見つかっています
そこで使われている水洗トイレは
今の水洗とトイレとはちょっと違って
川の水を街に引き込んで
そこにうんち おしっこを落とし込んで
それを川へ押し戻すという仕組みです
ローマ帝国の時にはこのトイレというものが
全盛期を迎えます
街中に公衆トイレが設置されます
しかしながら キリスト教の教えで
トイレと言うものは不浄である
というところから
公衆の場から姿を消してしまいます
なので公衆のものだったトイレが
個人のもののトイレとなり
そこで出てきたのが
「おまる」です
家の中でおまるにうんち おしっこ
用を足すわけですが
その中身をその当時の人たちは
どのように処理していたでしょうか？
階段を下りるのが面倒臭いなと
感じ始めた人達は
窓から外へ投げ捨てるんです
道路は
うんちやおしっこでべちゃべちゃですし
街を歩いていると
上から
うんち おしっこが降ってくる訳です
最悪です
それを避けるために生まれた物が
今やおしゃれアイテムとなっている
ハイヒール
もしくは つばの広い帽子だったり
マントと言われてます
必要は発明の母なんですね
うんちやおしっこが街に溢れていて
まぁ 汚い 臭い だけで
済めばいいんですけど
それだけじゃ全然済まないんです
それが原因でチフスやペストなど
伝染病が流行ります
大流行します
14世紀中頃には
世界人口の３分の１が
それで命を落としたと言われています
どうにかしなきゃいかんということで
16世紀頃になって
初めて現代型の水洗トイレというものが
発明されました
これによって
建物に溜まっていたうんち おしっこ[を]
川や海などに運ぶことに
成功ができた訳です
ただこれでは完璧じゃなくて
20世紀になって
下水処理施設 この下水処理技術が発明されて
安全で衛生的なトイレというのが
完結することができました
じゃあ その時 日本って
どうだったんでしょうか？
日本では鎌倉時代位から
お寺にトイレというものがどんどん設置されて
一般化していきます
その当時の日本では
ごはんを食べて
その後うんちやおしっこを出して
出てきたものを集めて
肥料にするために寝かして
そして作られた肥料を
野菜を育てるために使って
その育った野菜を
また食べるというような
循環型の暮らし
というものがそこにありました
江戸の街では
「肥桶（ひおけ）」と呼ばれる
うんちやおしっこを溜めるための
桶を持った人たちが
長屋の主を訪れて
「そのうんち いくらで売ってくれ」
と言うような状態です
この当時 うんちやおしっこは
価値あるものだったので
金肥と呼ばれていました
当時の日本は鎖国をしていたので
輸出入に制限があります
なのでその時の日本は
ほぼ完全な循環型の暮らし
というのがされていました
ただ 開国されますと
その循環型のサイクルというのは
少しずつ崩れていきます
人は仕事を求めて
都市にどんどん集まってきます
人が集まるとそこで生み出されるのは
うんちやおしっこです
必要量以上にうんちやおしっこが集まると
価値はどんどん下落します
今までお金で売れていた
うんちやおしっこという物が
それからはお金を払って
うんちやおしっこを運んでもらう
そういう物になりました
さらにボットン便所に溜まった
うんちやおしっこは
バキュームカーを使って
農村部に運ばれて行きます
その肥料を作るのにも
だんだんお金が掛かってきます
そして海外からは
安い化学肥料が輸入されて来ます
うんち おしっこを
肥料化するコストが掛かるのに比べて
海に捨てた方が速いし安いということで
出て来たうんち おしっこを海に捨てる
ということが始まります
そしてその海に捨てる事が
環境問題 環境破壊に繋がる
という事で禁止されてからは
下水処理技術が日本にも導入されて
今のような形で安全で快適に不自由無く
トイレが使えるように日本もなった訳です
じゃ 考えてみてください
今 私たちが使っているトイレですが
世界に目を向けると
果たしてどうなんでしょうか？
国連によると
25億人の人達が
定期的にトイレにアクセスできない
[という]状況が今でも続いています
そして10億人の人達は
屋外で排泄する事を余儀なくされています
その人達がほとんど住んでいるのは
新興国です
新興国は今 人口が爆発的に増えています
人々は仕事を求めて都市に集まります
ただお金が無いので住む場所は
上水道や下水道インフラの整っていない
スラム地区です
この写真は
私が今働いている
ケニアの最大のスラム
キベラになります
ここにはもちろん
上下水道インフラはありません
ただ公衆トイレは
数少ないですが存在します
ただこのトイレを使うのには
10円や５円 お金が掛かります
そして夜 このトイレに行くことは
大変危険です
子供達や女性がそこのトイレに行く
なんてことは以ての外です
じゃ お金が無い人
そして 夜トイレに行きたくなった人は
どうやって用を足すんでしょうか？
その一つの方法がこれです
「フライングトイレ」です
名前の通り 空を飛ぶトイレです
これは
「どうしてもトイレに行きたくなった
でもトイレがない どうしよう？」
となったら
とりあえずそこにあるビニール袋に
「うんち」っていう感じです
ただ家に置いておくと
すごく匂うので
このトイレを
外に向かって放り投げるんです
（笑）
だからフライングトイレなんです
じゃ 投げた先はどうなっちゃうの？
これはそのキベラの一角です
土山のようにビニール袋に入ったごみが
積み重なっていますし
この中の半分位はそのフライングトイレ
うんちやおしっこが入ったものです
ビニール袋が破れて
簡単に外にこぼれ出します
そしてその傍では
この写真にも写っているように
子供達が楽しそうに
泥で遊ぶんです
この泥［には］うんちやおしっこが
入っている可能性がすごい高いです
その手のまま
彼女たち 彼らはごはんを食べます
だから下痢になる子が
すごく多いんです
ユニセフ[によると] 一日に1,400人の
子供たちがこれで命を落としています
何とかしなきゃいけないです
先進国が採った方法を
採ることが一番いいかもしれない
だけれども
それができないんです
水が無いんです
８億人の人達は
未だに飲む水を手に入れるのに
苦労してます
先ほどのスラムでも上水道が無いので
生きるための水を手に入れるのが
精いっぱいです
そんな水をうんちやおしっこを流すため
なんかに使うことはできません
そう！だから私は今 ケニアで
この問題を解決するために働いています
私が今 作っているのは
「循環型無水トイレシステム」
という新しいトイレです
名前の通り 水を使いません
そして出てきたうんち おしっこを
肥料にして土に戻す
循環型の仕組みを目指しています
ここで目指している 私の
ありたい社会の姿というのは
食べて 出して 集めて
また肥料にするために寝かして
野菜を育てて
またその野菜をまた食べるという
循環型の暮らしです
皆さん 見覚えありますよね？
そうです
私たちが日本でやっていたその暮らしです
また私はその暮らしを
ケニアで実現したいと思っています
なぜ私が
「循環型」にこだわっているかというと
人口が増えると水の問題と併せて
食料の問題が出てくるんです
私達のうんちやおしっこには
まだまだ使える栄養素が残っている
だからその資源を賢く回収して
またそれを土に戻すことで
環境にやさしい社会というのが持続できます
このコンセプトは十分解っていただける
ケニアの人達も解かるかもしれないけれども
昔のようなボットン便所だったら
「こんなの使いたくない」と
なかなか受け入れてもらえません
だから私たちは快適性にもこだわってます
私が作っている循環型無水トイレは
うんち おしっこを
分けて回収することができます
これによって匂いの元である
アンモニアの発生を抑えることができます
この「循環型の暮らし」ということ
そして「快適なトイレ」ということを
このアイディアをケニアの人たちに伝えて
理解して 共感を得て
それでケニアにこれを普及させていきたい
それが私の毎日の活動です
イギリスで500年前に
現代型の水洗トイレが開発されてから
今 私は 次の世代に繋がるトイレ
という物を開発している
そんな意気込みで毎日奮闘しています
私はこのトイレをケニアで成功させた後
やりたいことがあります
それはこのトイレを日本に持って帰りたい
［という］ことです
何ででしょうか？
それは日本が地震大国だからです
一度大きな地震が起きると
高い確率で断水が起きます
断水が起きると
今ある水洗トイレは使い物になりません
喩え 水道が直ったとしても
下水道管や下水処理場が壊れたままだと
トイレは使えないんです
仮設トイレはもちろん来ますが
回収するためのトラックが来なかったら
使い物になりません
私たちに残されているトイレの方法は
ビニール袋にうんちやおしっこをして
それを回収場に持っていく
まさに私がスラムで見ている生活を
しなければなりません
次に起こるかもしれない
災害に立ち向かうためにも
上下水道インフラに依存しないトイレの開発が
今から必要だと思っています
そして水を使うことも
日本ではもったいないと思っています
日本は水が豊かな国と
皆さん 思っているかもしれませんが
決して豊かではないんです
雨は多く降るんですけれども
溜めることができません
すぐに海に流れ出してしまいます
そして日本は水を輸入する
最大の輸入国としても知られています
食べ物をたくさん輸入してますが
その食べ物を作るために
海外で多くの水を使っています
日本でそれだけの食べ物を
作ろうとしても
水が無くて
賄うことができないんです
水を作るために私たちは
たくさんのエネルギーを使ってます
川上から川下まで 上水処理・下水処理
これを繰り返して
再利用して 何とか使っています
解りにくいかもしれませんが
日本でも今
水面下ではトイレとの戦いが続いていますし
災害が一度起きると
この戦いに私たちは直面する可能性があります
だから私からこの戦いを迎［える］準備として
提案があります
みなさん トイレに愛を向けてみませんか？
今まで意識していなかったトイレに
意識を向けて考えてみませんか？
トイレを考えること
それは「今の私たちの環境」
そして「私たちの未来の環境」
を考えることにも繋がります
恥ずかしがらずに
みなさん トイレを愛してみましょう
すごく簡単なことかもしれませんが
例えば 皆さん
トイレに大小洗浄機能が付いているのを
ご存知ですか？
ちゃんと使い分けていますか？
あの機能は日本で生まれたもので
海外ではとても絶賛されています
正しく使い分ければ 家族四人の場合
年間2,000リットルの水を節約できます
あとトイレをするのに必ず必要な
トイレットペーパー［を］
使い過ぎていませんかね？
トイレットパーパーって実は
うんちに比べて
流すために使う水とか
処理に使うエネルギーが多いんです
なのでこれを
ちょっとでも減らすことっていうのが
環境のためにもエネルギーを削減するためにも
すごく役に立つんです
トイレっていうのはそこが決して
出口ではなくて 実は入口なんです
うんちの旅って
そこから始まるんです
その旅に少しこう
想いを馳せて考えてみること
それが実は環境を考えることに
繋がっていきます
皆さんが少しでもトイレに関心を持って
ちょっとずつの愛を注ぎ込んでもらうこと
それがこの後の
将来的な環境にも繋がっていきます
今言った少しの改善活動 行動は
今の環境を変えるのにも役に立ちますし
将来的に循環型無水トイレが
日本に入ってきた時の
準備にも繋がっていきます
皆さん トイレに愛を向けてみましょう
改めて最後に
「トイレに愛を！」
ありがとうございました
（拍手）